[Music]  New York City Mayor Bloomberg of course  came under fire this week after he  proposed banning the sale of soft drinks  over 16 ounces now a lot of people are  very upset about this but one company in  New Jersey already taking advantage  check it out  tired of the man telling you how much  soda you can handle exercise your  freedom to chug at Johnny's slurps soda  Tyria at Johnny's slurps you decide how  much soda you can drink bring any  container and hook pump it full of cold  refreshing American soda at Johnny  slurps what you feel is your business  what you fill it with is ours and as  always kids under five drink free  the band spreads to New Jersey there's  always Johnny slurp so DeBarge swim out  and drink yourself stupid  Johnny slurps OH - Tyrion Jersey City  right next to Johnny slips into a pond  [Applause]